la sífilis es un tipo de enfermedad o
infección de transmisión sexual es
causada por diminutas bacterias
enrolladas o en espiral llamadas
treponema pálidoum el primer síntoma que
puede notarse es una o más úlceras
llamadas chancros que suelen ser
indoloras y aparecen en el lugar por
donde entró la bacteria en el organismo
sin tratamiento la enfermedad puede
seguir avanzando hacia otras tres etapas
durante un período de semanas meses o
años
puede provocar graves problemas de salud
como daño cerebral ceguera o incluso la
muerte
la buena noticia Es que la sífilis puede
tratarse y curarse con diferentes
formulaciones de un antibiótico llamado
penicilina
por lo general solo basta una dosis
inyectada en la cadera o en la nalga
para eliminar la infección sin embargo
si se ha extendido a otras partes del
cuerpo como los ojos el cerebro o la
médula espinal es posible que se
necesite más de una dosis las cuales
deben inyectarse directamente en las
venas las personas con infecciones
graves como la neurocífilis pueden
necesitar tratamiento en el hospital si
no se puede utilizar la penicilina se
pueden administrar otros antibióticos
como la doxiciclina los antibióticos
actúan eliminando las bacterias que
causan la sífilis no obstante Es
importante saber que el tratamiento no
reparará ningún daño que la enfermedad
ya haya causado en el organismo puede
reducir el riesgo de contraer sífilis si
solo mantiene relaciones sexuales con
una pareja estable que no tenga
relaciones sexuales con otras personas y
que haya obtenido un resultado negativo
en la prueba de detección de sífilis
también puede practicar sexo seguro
lo que significa tomar medidas antes y
durante las relaciones sexuales para
evitar contraer o propagar la sífilis
por ejemplo utilizar preservativos de
forma correcta cada vez que tienes
relaciones sexuales puede reducir el
riesgo sin embargo si entra en contacto
con una úlcera en una zona del cuerpo de
su pareja no cubierta por el
preservativo puede contraer la sífilis
la forma más fiable de evitar contraer
sífilis es practicar la abstinencia lo
que significa no practicar sexo vaginal
anal u oral para obtener más información
sobre el tratamiento y la prevención de
la sífilis consulte a su médico